OK.
Let's go next to our caller from the 773 area
code who's calling today from 773 meeting
contract in college.
Hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Hey, David.
Hi, my name is Barry.
I want to apologize.
I've been wanting to become a member for a
while, but it seems like every time I want
to become a member, something crazy happens.
Right.
But the reason why I'm calling is because
of the election in Wisconsin.
So like I write in to the show like super
tax often about stuff.
What's going on in Wisconsin?
I'm working on like a campaign here.
And, you know, I've been making around 200,
250 calls a day to residents here trying to
get them to get absentee ballots.
And they literally ran out of absentee ballots.
They're sending people absentee ballots late
and then it's due on Thursday.
But, you know, people are going to be able
to get sent out and they only are going to
have 12 voting locations in the Milwaukee
area.
Right.
It's usually over 100.
I guess my question is, what effect do you
think that this is going to have on like the
rest of the election?
Like the fact that this election is still
going to go on?
Yeah.
So earlier this week, we did a story about
how Nancy Pelosi is now saying we really need
to do vote by mail.
And I fear that this this is going to have
a huge effect is my fear, especially because
people staying home is is very much partisan
in the sense that Republicans are much more
likely to not take the virus seriously and
to just go out in public.
So if we get to November, it is very likely
that if there are still virus fears and it
seems like that's certainly plausible, it
may even be the start of the second wave at
that point in time.
We don't know.
My guess is if it's not vote by mail, you
are going to have way more people who would
be going out to vote for the Democratic nominee
staying home versus trumpets who are more
likely to just say, hey, this is no big deal,
I'm going to go out and vote.
So I believe we need to go to a full vote
by mail system.
All we're really we have the infrastructure.
We're basically just saying let's give an
absentee ballot to everyone instead of having
to justify why you get an absentee ballot.
Yeah, I think also the last question I was
having, like my girlfriend lost her job, know
several coworkers that they had to let go
because we went from canvasing to just 100
percent phone baking and so they don't need
as many people.
Right.
And, you know, leases are coming, you know,
do that.
People have to decide when they're going to
move.
Yeah.
And like didn't like this time is like the
worst time ever to try to find a new job.
Yes.
Because I've been like looking for different
jobs for her.
And the interviews you got to do interviews
on phone calls, our Skype calls.
You have to get trains if they do hire you
remotely.
Right.
Yeah.
There are all sorts of follow on effects that
we still don't know the full scope of.
Like as you're pointing out on the first day
of the month, leases or do mortgages or do
a lot of people aren't going to be able to
pay those that will then have a subsequent
effect and then you'll have people needing
jobs.
But it being a terrible time to go and look
for a job.
And a lot of companies are not.
Not only are they not hiring, they're laying
people off.
What I come away with is the stimulus probably
needs to be bigger and two thirds of it shouldn't
have gone to corporations.
More should have gone to people.
So we can give them more than twelve hundred
bucks.
Yeah, this the last thing I want to let you
know that my girlfriend was a very nonpolitical
person.
And now I have her watching your show almost
every day.
Love it.
All right.
We'll say hi to her for me.
Okay.
All right.
We'll talk to you later.
Great to hear from Barry in Wisconsin.